Eric Voss with another new Rockstar's
hot take why is it that the scariest
scenes in HBO's The Last of Us are not
really the fungus infected
post-apocalypse but in the prologue
scenes of episode 1 2 a 1968 talk show
discussing epidemiology a pre-outbreak
day in 2003 Jakarta well both of these
scenes are shot like horror films both
gradually pushed the camera in closer
and closer to an expert telling us that
we're doomed and the fact that both
scenes are set in the past to us a past
that we know and recognize leads us to
think that we could be in that
post-apocalyptic present right now after
having missed the warning signs decades
ago of our world I mean the world has
only gotten hotter since 2003 and since
1968 so could every mushroom right now
be trying to kill us